皆さんこんにちははじめ社長です先日線劇団スカッシュさんの2nd チャンネルの
方からあの pdr さんタグを達也さんから
舞わせていただきました
tatsuya さんありがとうございます
tatsuya さほんとあの今度ねちょっと一杯飲みに市場際は是非
まず未成年だった pdr さんタグを
ちょっと
こばと
入っていこうと思います
ちょっと甘詰の話になるかなぁ
つまらないからん
見ない方がいいでしょそうユーザーネームの由来ということでテーマなんで02一応
メックスって言うか買ったらなぁ
02ちゃんというのは誕生日なんですよ誕生日がバレンタインじゃないです2月水飲ん
で
メックスっていうのは
自分でもよくわかんないんですよ
カメックスが好きなわけでもないしそもそもなぜ発展カンパニーっていう名前で
始めようと思ったかというと僕1年生の時
そのと同じ3人となんか
学生起業って
流行っていたんですよ
疾風たというかなんかその
大学生でも
改札くれるって言う話を聞いてじゃあ作ろうってなって
者もシンプルにはじめカンパニーでしょうみたいな感じだってちょっとおやつ
カンパニーみたいなんですけど
そこから始めカンパニーくなって
言葉といろいろこうなんか経済のなんかどうしたらカイザー立てれるかとか
考え
たんですけど僕が勝手に広
いい方向に進んだが悪い方向に住んだかわかんないんですけど
動画投稿
動画投稿って言う
スターいるにしちゃったんですよ
好きな季節は
僕は春が好きです出会いがあれば別れます
好きなんです春が
嫌いな食べ物は
なすときゅうりです
好きなキャラクターは
もうこれしかいないんですよマネージャーん
じゃない
うわぁ可愛い
うわぁ
なんでこんな風にリボンがあってここにもリボンがあるっていうね
松木ながすげーでしょ
明日のかわいいです
可愛いとかじゃなくてもう
愛してますよ
こんな白いでこねー
もう北絶対買いたいですも候ひこう言う猫と生活したいです
好きなそういう物トップ3ということで
サーフィン
シャーペン4日
だったのって
このシャーペンが一番好きですこれドクターグリップの黒いやつんですけど
これが一番好きですよこれで受験大学受験買ったようなもんですからね
ティッシュですね
ん
僕は1年ず鼻炎なので摂取がないと注ぎます
それ人間とは macbook ですかもしれないですかね
どうやって持ってきた pdr さん
しかちんさん
瀬戸康史さん
ぜひ何フラッシュ散歩グっていうちょっと
ちょっとをなんかソ32に回すということなんですけど
変化球
ここでた普通にこうついのメンバーありましたら面白くないと思うんでー
まあとりあえず
トミックさんとビックさんに申します
とミクさんのはちょっと
なんかしてくれるでしょ神谷は件
神山君に回せますよ神谷向けのエロさはもう
スーパーエロティカセブンですよ
ツアーここはブラックすぐに回したいと思います
あの大きいものを作るのが好きなんで
大きいものばっかり作ってる変な人です
以上の3人にをさせていただけますさんの本当に
達也さんの日に行きましょう
ん